problemas número 76 en una bolsa tenemos
dos canicas verdes y cuatro canicas
blancas de hecho vamos a ir dibujando
las esta es una bolsa y en esta bolsa
tengo dos canicas verdes y cuatro
canicas blancas y en una segunda bolsa
tenemos tres canicas verdes tres verdes
y una canica blanca
si memo aleatoriamente saca una canica
de cada bolsa cuál es la probabilidad de
que ambas canicas sean verdes bueno
veamos de la primera bolsa cuál es la
probabilidad de sacar una canica verde
tengo 2 canicas verdes de un total de 1
2 3 4 5 6 canicas de esta bolsa dos
sextos que esto es igual a un tercio
y de la segunda bolsa tengo tres canicas
verdes en un total de cuatro canicas
para obtener la probabilidad de que o
sacar una canica de cada bolsa
estas dos sean verdes tenemos que
multiplicar un tercio por tres cuartos
y esto va a ser igual a un cuarto
porque bueno esto se va con esto y me
queda un cuarto veamos el siguiente
problema el número 77 una caja contiene
7 canicas grandes rojas de hecho vamos a
dibujarla tenemos una caja dentro de
esta caja tengo 7 canicas grandes rojas
cinco canicas grandes amarillas
las pequeñas rojas
y cinco canicas pequeñas amarillas si se
saca una canica de forma aleatoria cuál
es la probabilidad de que sea amarilla
dado que se saca una de las canicas
grandes quizás a ustedes les parezca un
poco complicado este planteamiento de
probabilidades condicionales lo que nos
piden es la probabilidad de sacar una
canica amarilla siempre y cuando sea
grande una canica grande o tal que
hayamos sacado una canica grande
no es tan difícil lo que tenemos que
hacer es concentrarnos ya que sacamos
una canica y fue grande pues vamos a
concentrarnos en el universo de canicas
grandes que son estas
entonces la probabilidad de sacar una
canica amarilla tenemos 5 canicas
amarillas
de las grandes
un total de 75 12 canicas grandes sin
conocidos
esta es la probabilidad que nos están
preguntando 5 12 a 2
vemos el siguiente problema
número 78 juan quiere aplicar para el
equipo de béisbol o de baloncesto pero
no paramos la probabilidad de que juan
pruebe para entrar al equipo de béisbol
y aplique para kutcher es del 42% pues
la probabilidad de que juan aplique para
entrar al equipo de baloncesto bueno
aquí lo que nos dicen es que va a
aplicar o para baloncesto o para béisbol
pero no para ambos
la probabilidad de que pruebe para
entrar al equipo de béisbol y aplique
para kutcher es de 42 por ciento es
decir que el juan elija esto de aplicar
para el equipo de béisbol y para kutcher
esta probabilidad de aquí es del 42% lo
que nos piden es ver la probabilidad de
que aplique para el equipo de baloncesto
esto es lo que nos piden y vamos a
llamarle a esto la variable x
si esto es x esto de acá va a ser 1 - x
si juan aplica para el equipo de
baloncesto hay un 80 por ciento de
probabilidad de que aplique para hacer
defensa hay un 20% de probabilidad de
que aplique para hacer delantero si
quisiéramos saber la probabilidad de que
sea baloncesto y delantero será x por
20% si fuera 50% xy delantero sería el
10% apliquemos la misma lógica en este
otro lado si aplica para el béisbol
habrá un 70% de probabilidades de que
aplique para kutcher y nos dicen que la
probabilidad combinada de estos dos es
del 42%
así que tenemos lo voy a escribir de
este lado esta probabilidad 1 - x x 0.7
que es este 70% va a ser igual a 0.42
0.42 o 42% que es lo que nos están
diciendo acá vamos a desarrollar esto
vamos a dividir todo entre 0.7 y me va a
quedar 1 - x igual a 0.42 entre 0.7 esto
es igual a 0.6 y nunca está de más
verificarlo con la realidad el 70% de
algo es 60%
bueno el 70% del 60% es el 42% así que 1
- x es igual a punto 6
esto es punto 6 entonces cuanto a base
de x si este 60% entonces vamos a
despejar x1 menos x es igual a punto 6
restamos 1 en ambos lados me queda menos
x igual a menos punto 4 multiplicamos
por menos sólo ambos lados de la
ecuación y nos queda que x es igual a
punto 4 o al 40% eso es igual a 0.4
que es nuestra opción y veamos el
siguiente problema el dueño de una
empresa debe contratar trabajadores por
temporada conforme aumenta la necesidad
la siguiente lista muestra el número de
empleados contratados mensualmente por
un periodo de cinco meses 4 13 5 6 9 si
la media de esta información es
aproximadamente 7 cual es la desviación
estándar de la población para estos
datos aproxima la respuesta a la décima
más cercana hay varias formas de
conceptualizar la desviación estándar a
mí me gusta pensar en ella como la
distancia promedio de la media si
quieren una representación visual de
ella vamos a dibujar unos ejes
coordinados este va a ser el eje de las
yes este va a ser el eje de las equis y
voy a dibujar cada uno de los puntos que
nos dicen son 5 puntos 1 2
1 2 3 4 5 nos dicen que para el primer
mes se contrataron 4 personas
imaginemos que está el 4 acá así que
aquí está nuestro primer punto en el
segundo mes se contrataron 13 personas
imaginemos que está aquí el valor del 13
y va a estar aquí este otro punto
tercer mes se contratan cinco personas
imaginemos que está aquí el 5 así que va
a estar este punto acá
el cuarto mes son seis personas vamos a
imaginar que este es el 6 así que estará
por acá y en el quinto mes son 9
personas vamos a imaginar más o menos
que están por acá el valor del 9
así que este es el valor en el quinto
más nos dicen que el promedio o la media
está en 7 aproximadamente así que sí
aquí está el 7 mi promedio va a estar
más o menos por acá más o menos ahí
están 7 usuarios no tienen que dibujar
esto para resolver este problema pero yo
quiero que les quede claro este concepto
y no lo olviden cuando tengan 32 años
esta línea es el promedio de estos
números y nos dan este dato para
ahorrarnos tiempo nosotros pudimos
haberlo calculado
sumando estas cantidades y dividiendo el
resultado entre 5 para así sacar el
promedio la desviación estándar es la
distancia promedio hacia la media o el
promedio puede recordar lo de la raíz
cuadrada de la varianza y la varianza es
el cuadrado de la distancia sea la media
cuál es la distancia entre 4 y
en este 4 y 7 esta distancia de aquí acá
es de 3 solo queremos conocer la
distancia no lo cual está por encima o
por debajo por eso algunas personas
dicen que la varianza la voy a escribir
acá la varianza es igual en este caso es
cuatro menos siete al cuadrado y esto es
y verán que la desviación estándar es
igual a la raíz cuadrada de la varianza
es igual a 3 pero ustedes pueden también
decir que esta desviación estándar es el
valor absoluto de 47 para mí esto es más
intuitivo pues es ver qué tan lejos se
encuentra del 7 todos estos valores no
importa si están por encima o por debajo
de la media solo quiero conocer la
distancia entre ellos y quiero promediar
cada uno de estos valores bueno de hecho
esto no es la división extender esto es
uno de sus elementos que tengo que
promediar con los demás la notación
apropiada para esto es la varianza es
igual a la suma
y la suma de las diferencias entre los n
puntos de información y debemos tomar el
valor absoluto de cada uno de ellos
el valor absoluto de x a la y menos
es la media y la anotación bueno suele
complicarse pero es la suma de todo esto
/ / end / n cuando tomen clases de
estadística verán a detalle todo esto
pero el chiste es que nos interesa el
promedio de la distancias a la media que
es más sencillo de calcular todo lo que
he hecho hasta el momento en este
problema no tienen que hacerlo para el
examen bueno entonces sumamos todas las
distancias ya habíamos visto que la
distancia de aquí acá es 3 la siguiente
distancia de 13 a 7 esta distancia 6 la
distancia de 5 a 7 es 2 la distancia de
6 a 7 es una la distancia de 9 a 7 es 2
así que tenemos estos valores 3 6 2
2 sumamos todas estas distancias nos dan
tres más 69 + 211 + 112 214 y eso lo
dividimos entre 5 que es el número de
puntos que tengo y el promedio es de 2.8
aunque no tengo una opción con este
valor y me estoy dando cuenta que me
estoy quedando sin tiempo bueno
continuamos con esto en el siguiente
vídeo